Alice:这睫毛就粘在
Alice: This eyelash just sticks on...
Lucia: 我看看还有什么喝的
Lucia: Let me see what else we have to drink.
Lucia: 哈哈我已经哈哈
Lucia: Haha, I already...
Lucia: 啊不过喝的好像大部分在楼上
Lucia: Ah, but most of the drinks seem to be upstairs.
Alice:哎呀哎呀
Alice: Oh no, oh no.
Alice:我要烦死了
Alice: I'm getting so annoyed.
Alice:换镊子
Alice: Change the tweezers.
Tasha:  要换个镊子
Alice:我应该还有别的
Alice: I should have another pair.
Alice:果然有别的
Alice: Of course, I have another pair.
Alice: 那我要生气了
Alice: Now I'm getting really mad.
Lucia: 这个绿豆饼是用来吃的还是
Lucia: Are these mung bean cakes for eating or...
Tasha: 用来吃的
Tasha: For eating.
Lucia: 啊有人想吃吗
Lucia: Ah, does anyone want to eat them?
Tasha: 嗯我觉得还可以再来两瓶养乐多
Tasha: Hmm, I think we could have two more bottles of Yakult.
Lucia: 哈哈来两两瓶
Lucia: Haha, two more bottles?
Lucia: 什么啊可以可以
Lucia: What? Okay, sure.
Tasha: 哎养乐多啊
Tasha: Hey, Yakult!
Lucia: 帮你拿
Lucia: I'll get it for you.
Lucia: 刚好我在这
Lucia: I'm right here anyway.
Tasha: 养乐多哦哦
Tasha: Yakult, oh, oh.
Lucia: 那个掉到后面了我先把它拿出来
Lucia: It fell behind, I'll get it.
Lucia: 这个这个绿豆饼是我们直接可以吃
Lucia: Can we eat these mung bean cakes directly?
Lucia: 还是要用来做原料
Lucia: Or do we need to use them as ingredients?
Tasha: 直接直接吃啊
Tasha: Just eat them directly.
Lucia: 直接吃
Lucia: Eat directly.
Lucia: 哈哈哈get了
Lucia: Haha, got it.
Alice:夹带了一包私货
Alice: Smuggling in some private stash?
Tasha: 都被你发现了
Tasha: You caught me.
Lucia: 哈哈哈就是当我饿了的时候
Lucia: Haha, it's for when I'm hungry.
Lucia: 是哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:好这个又弄在镊子上了
Alice: Okay, this got on the tweezers again.
Lucia: 要喝吗
Lucia: Want a drink?
Tasha: 我不喝养乐多谢谢
Tasha: I don't drink Yakult, thanks.
Lucia: 你是不喝酸奶类的制品
Lucia: You don't drink yogurt products?
Tasha: 我喝纯酸奶
Tasha: I drink plain yogurt.
Lucia: hello
Lucia: Hello.
Shure: 我回来了
Shure: I'm back.
Lucia: 欢迎
Lucia: Welcome.
Shure: 大家好
Shure: Hi everyone.
Alice:喝不了一点
Alice: Can't drink even a bit.
Alice:好了你开始吧
Alice: Alright, you start.
Tasha:  我们开始了贴睫毛大战哈哈哈
Tasha: We're starting the eyelash sticking battle, hahaha.
其他人：我靠哇
Others: Wow, oh my!
其他人：这么多吃的啊
Others: So much food!
其他人：昨天还是空的
Others: It was empty yesterday.
其他人：我操这他妈捡一分慢慢烤呗
Others: Damn, let's just grill one at a time slowly.
Shure: 慢慢考呗
Shure: Let's grill slowly.
Jake: 哎你好你好你好
Jake: Hey, hello, hello, hello.
Jake: 你好你好
Jake: Hello, hello.
Jake: 你好你好你好
Jake: Hello, hello, hello.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hi
Jake: 眼镜呢
Jake: Where are the glasses?
Shure: 眼镜在我包包里
Shure: The glasses are in my bag.
Jake: 导出来了吗
Jake: Have you exported it?
Shure: 还没导出来
Shure: Not yet.
Jake: 行那你给我导一下
Jake: Okay, then export it for me.
Shure: 突然发现那什么
Shure: I just realized something.
Jake: 卡拉OK OK吗
Jake: Is the karaoke okay?
Alice:你不要把你的睫毛给夹一下
Alice: Don't curl your eyelashes.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 答辩OK
Jake: The defense went okay.
Shure: 还还OK
Shure: It was okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Shure: 安迪人特好
Shure: Andy is really nice.
Shure: 他非常有耐心
Shure: He is very patient.
Shure: 虽然我答的是一个答辩但是他
Shure: Even though I only answered one question, he...
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：跟你说个逆天的
Other: Let me tell you something crazy.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
其他人： 那天晚上学姐开了20分钟车
Other: That night, the senior drove for 20 minutes.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
其他人：然后扣了6分
Other: And got 6 points deducted.
Jake: 卧槽为什么
Jake: Damn, why?
其他人：因为闯红灯了
Other: Because she ran a red light.
Jake: 闯红灯
Jake: Ran a red light?
Jake: 学姐开车闯红灯
Jake: The senior ran a red light?
其他人：那天晚上没看见
Other: She didn't see it that night.
Jake: 哦那也不是他的问题
Jake: Oh, then it's not her fault.
Jake: 路的问题
Jake: It's the road's fault.
其他人：北京的问题
Other: It's Beijing's fault.
Jake: 北京的问题
Jake: It's Beijing's fault.
其他人：我妈刚才在路上
Other: My mom was just on the road.
其他人： 一路学法减分
Other: Learning traffic laws to reduce points.
Alice:他不是会送你一个小的吗
Alice: Doesn't he give you a small gift?
其他人：学完法减完分
Other: After learning and reducing points.
其他人：减了一分
Other: She reduced one point.
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
其他人：就让我看交通视频
Other: They just made me watch traffic videos.
其他人：考试减了一分
Other: Took a test and reduced one point.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 现在考5分了是吧
Jake: Now we need to score 5 points, right?
Lucia: 没什么啊
Lucia: It's nothing.
Shure: 没醒是吗
Shure: Haven't woken up, right?
Lucia: 醒了醒了
Lucia: I'm awake, I'm awake.
Jake: 打工呢好像
Jake: Working, it seems.
Lucia: 我们我们上午已经已经录了一段了
Lucia: We've already recorded a segment in the morning.
Alice:们已经结束一轮活
Alice: We've finished a round of work.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:  结束一轮活动
Tasha: Finished a round of activities.
Alice:结束一轮活动了
Alice: Finished a round of activities.
Jake: 哦对然后现在已经开始主播模式了
Jake: Oh, right, and now we're in streaming mode.
Jake: 就是眼镜已经不当眼镜用了就
Jake: So the glasses are no longer used as glasses.
其他人：咱们要导数据吗
Others: Do we need to export the data?
Jake: 要要要这个这个
Jake: Yes, yes, this, this.
Jake: 很重要这个很重要
Jake: It's very important, very important.
Shure: 这个珍贵素材啊
Shure: This is precious material.
Jake: 好好好行
Jake: Okay, okay, sure.
Jake: 眼镜先给我
Jake: Give me the glasses first.
Jake: 我我先倒一个
Jake: I'll transfer one first.
Shure: 人类恋爱日常素材
Shure: Human love daily material.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Whoa.
Jake: 有点牛逼
Jake: Kinda awesome.
Alice:我要画眼线
Alice: I need to draw eyeliner.
Tasha: 我不画
Tasha: I won't draw.
Alice:我可以给你画挑
Alice: I can draw it for you.
Shure: 挑不了能拨的剪不能拨的
Shure: What can't be picked can't be cut.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 这这这个都可以
Jake: This, this, all of this is fine.
Jake: 亲啊
Jake: Dear.
Jake: 我是在中间哦
Jake: I'm in the middle.
Jake: 我要把这个挪开
Jake: I need to move this.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:应该先画眼线再
Alice: Should draw eyeliner first and then...
Jake: 也可以我觉得对
Jake: Could be, I think, yeah.
其他人：要不要再学习学6遍
Others: Should we learn it 6 more times?
其他人：你学一遍扣那个
Others: You learn it once and then deduct that.
其他人：扣一分
Others: Deduct one point.
Shure: 得学
Shure: Have to learn.
Jake: 那学6遍不就好了吗是吗
Jake: Then learning it 6 times would work, right?
其他人：看它这个意思我个人感觉他是能扣个
Others: From what I understand, I think he can deduct...
Alice:我给你画个眼线吧
Alice: Let me draw some eyeliner for you.
Alice:我自己也不太会画但是我觉得
Alice: I'm not really good at it, but I think...
Jake: 来来看看一下
Jake: Come on, let's take a look.
Jake: 我迭代出来的
Jake: What I came up with.
Jake: 拍完带
Jake: Filmed it completely.
Alice:算了这个已经画坏了
Alice: Never mind, I already messed it up.
Alice:哈哈哈翻车
Alice: Haha, total fail.
Jake: 巧妙啊巧妙
Jake: Clever, really clever.
Jake: 巧妙是用的超能力
Jake: Clever use of superpowers.
Jake: 花了2,000块钱
Jake: Spent 2,000 bucks.
Jake: 买了15张SD卡
Jake: Bought 15 SD cards.
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this.
Jake: 那16张是吧
Jake: So, 16 cards, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:要不要给你画一个
Alice: Do you want me to draw one for you?
Lucia: 我正在想
Lucia: I'm thinking...
Alice:不太会哈哈
Alice: Not really good at it, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈我主要是懒得卸妆
Lucia: Haha, I'm just too lazy to remove makeup.
Lucia: 因为昨天刚洗完澡
Lucia: Because I just took a shower yesterday.
Lucia: 然后于是今天就什么都没化
Lucia: So today, I didn't put on any makeup.
Lucia: 这样晚上就不用卸妆了
Lucia: This way, I don't have to remove it tonight.
Shure: 这个视频能导出给我一份吗
Shure: Can you export this video for me?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 之之后都可以给你们
Jake: You can all have it later.
Jake: 然后但是要处理一下
Jake: But I need to process it first.
Jake: 因为这个文件格式不太对
Jake: Because the file format is not quite right.
Alice:化坏啊怎么办
Alice: It's messed up, what should I do?
Shure: 好的我只要我昨天晚上
Shure: Okay, I just need what I filmed last night.
Alice:啊化坏了
Alice: Ah, it's messed up.
Jake: 你别的不要也行
Jake: You don't need the rest, right?
Shure: 这个绝对有
Shure: This is definitely important.
Shure: 比较重要
Shure: Quite important.
Alice:太低了
Alice: Too low.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 以后是我的亡妻回忆录
Shure: This will be my memoir of my late wife.
Tasha:  下眼线应该粘哪啊
Tasha: Where should I stick the lower eyeliner?
Jake: 哈哈我草
Jake: Haha, oh my gosh.
Alice:你已经开始粘下边了吗
Alice: Are you already sticking the lower part?
Jake: 录下来了我草
Jake: I recorded it, oh my gosh.
Alice:你不是还没粘上面呢吗
Alice: Haven't you stuck the upper part yet?
Jake: 就是这边硬盘每人有一个
Jake: Everyone has a hard drive here.
Tasha: 一定要先粘上面的吗
Tasha: Do we have to stick it on the top first?
Alice:我也不知道可以吧都行
Alice: I don't know, maybe, anything's fine.
Jake: 还得专门有一台存呢
Jake: We need a special one for storage.
Jake: 现在都在
Jake: Everything is on them now.
Alice:哎怎么办化一半不想化了
Alice: Ugh, what do I do? I don't feel like finishing this.
Jake: 现在都在SD卡里面
Jake: Everything is on the SD cards now.
Jake: 根本导不出来
Jake: Can't even export them.
Jake: 太他妈慢了
Jake: It's so damn slow.
Jake: 15台太慢了
Jake: 15 devices are too slow.
Jake: 我靠妈的
Jake: Damn it.
其他人：导一条的多久啊
Others: How long does it take to export one?
Jake: 呃 1 pens
Jake: Uh, 1 pen.
Jake: 对大概真的就是他说是3个小时
Jake: Yeah, he said it takes about 3 hours.
Jake: 我估计一个小时
Jake: I think it's about an hour.
Jake: 一个小时一台
Jake: An hour per device.
Alice:算了影响全擦了
Alice: Forget it, just wipe everything.
Jake: 然后我现在就是有这么两
Jake: So now I have these two...
Jake: 就是相当于两波有SD卡
Jake: It's like two batches with SD cards.
Tasha: 算了不贴了
Tasha: Forget it, not sticking it anymore.
Tasha: 好难受啊
Tasha: This is so uncomfortable.
Jake: 所以说就是换一波下来
Jake: So we switch batches...
Alice:好难化啊
Alice: It's so hard to draw.
Jake: 然后开始疯狂导
Jake: Then start exporting like crazy.
Jake: 就是在这边就疯狂导
Jake: Just exporting like crazy here.
Lucia: 这个牌是什么牌可以看一眼吗
Lucia: What brand is this? Can I take a look?
Jake: 对就有轮换的时间
Jake: Yeah, there's rotation time.
Tasha: 这个是二奔DK
Tasha: This is Erben DK.
Jake: 不然根本他妈的一个小时导不出来
Jake: Otherwise, no way to export in an hour.
Jake: 焦头烂额
Jake: It's a mess.
Alice:谁来救救我呀
Alice: Someone save me!
Jake: 卧槽呵呵呵呵
Jake: Damn, hahaha.
Lucia: 我并不敢给别人花哈哈
Lucia: I don't dare to do makeup for others, haha.
Lucia: 我怕化完之后被别人追着打哈哈
Lucia: I'm afraid they'll chase me after it's done, haha.
Tasha: 豪情壮志的开始
Tasha: Starting with great ambition.
Tasha: 潦草的结束
Tasha: Ending in a mess.
Lucia: 我觉得你们画的挺好看的
Lucia: I think your makeup looks great.
Lucia: 就是那种裸妆的感觉
Lucia: It has that natural look.
Alice:你不贴了
Alice: You're not sticking it?
Tasha: 贴不上了
Tasha: I can't stick it anymore.
Shure: 中午你点什么
Shure: What did you order for lunch?
Alice:米村拌饭吃
Alice: Rice village bibimbap.
Shure: 还没开始吃呢
Shure: Haven't started eating yet.
Lucia: 好像还没到呢
Lucia: Seems like it's not here yet.
Alice:还没送到
Shure: 这是啥呀
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 这是失败
Shure: This is a failure.
Tasha:  嗯你吃一块
Tasha: Hmm, try a piece.
Lucia: 其实还挺好吃的
Lucia: It's actually quite tasty.
Tasha:  真的真的这是杨老师吃的
Tasha: Really, really, this is what Mr. Yang eats.
Tasha: 你尝他吃的
Tasha: Try what he's eating.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈我靠
Jake: Hahaha, oh my god.
Tasha:  这还有这还有别的你为什么不尝啊
Tasha: There's more, why don't you try it?
Lucia: 真挺好吃的
Lucia: It's really tasty.
Lucia: 这真挺好吃
Lucia: It's really good.
Lucia: 我早上吃了好多块
Lucia: I ate a lot of pieces this morning.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 真的
Lucia: Really.
Tasha: 那就好哈哈
Tasha: That's good, haha.
Lucia: 那个锅确实可能导热有点快
Lucia: Maybe that pot heats up too quickly.
Lucia: 就外面稍微有点焦
Lucia: So the outside is a bit burnt.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Lucia: 对焦的地方就会稍微有一点点苦
Lucia: The burnt parts are a bit bitter.
Lucia: 但是本身就是那些没有被烧焦的地方
Lucia: But the parts that aren't burnt are really delicious.
Lucia: 真的很好吃
Lucia: Really tasty.
Tasha: 好谢谢你明天还做给你吃
Tasha: Great, thank you. I'll make it for you again tomorrow.
Lucia: 不用谢真的挺好吃的
Lucia: No need to thank me. It's really good.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈好好好
Jake: Hahaha, okay, okay.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 发自内心的
Lucia: I mean it from the heart.
Tasha: 你是觉得蘸糖好吃吗
Tasha: Do you think it's better with sugar?
Lucia: 我觉得蘸不蘸糖都还不错
Lucia: I think it's good with or without sugar.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 作为一个北方人
Lucia: As a northerner,
Lucia: 就蘸不蘸糖都没所谓了
Lucia: it doesn't matter if there's sugar or not.
Jake: 嗯不准抽了上来吧
Jake: Hmm, no smoking. Come on up.
Alice:哈好你先画坏啊
Alice: Haha, okay, you draw first.
Tasha:  啊这个感觉
Tasha: Ah, this feeling.
Alice:不会画怎么办
Alice: What if I can't draw?
Jake: 抽烟被学姐骂是吧
Jake: You got scolded by the senior for smoking, right?
Alice:画不了
Alice: I can't draw it.
Jake: 学姐不骂你
Jake: The senior won't scold you.
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Just leave it like this.
Alice:烦死了
Alice: So annoying.
Tasha:  来打个腮红
Tasha: Come, let me put some blush on you.
Tasha: 再画个眉毛吗你
Tasha: Do you want me to do your eyebrows too?
Alice:怎么办想把它全擦了
Alice: What should I do? I want to erase everything.
Tasha: 差不多挺好的
Tasha: It's almost good enough.
Lucia: 我觉得你这个睫睫毛贴挺好看的
Lucia: I think your false lashes look pretty good.
Tasha: 睫毛贴的挺好看
Tasha: The false lashes look nice.
Alice:眼线怎么办
Alice: What about the eyeliner?
Alice:给它擦了擦不掉
Alice: I tried wiping it off but it won't come off.
Lucia: 很卷翘很好看
Lucia: It's really curled and looks great.
Alice:眉毛吧
Alice: Eyebrows.
Tasha: 咱俩的笔都是这样子卷起来的是吧
Tasha: Our pencils are both like this, right?
Alice:眉毛
Alice: Eyebrows.
Alice:我我没有专门的眉那啥我都是用眼影
Alice: I don't have a specific eyebrow pencil, I just use eyeshadow.
Tasha: 哦因为跟你的发色比较接近是吧
Tasha: Oh, because it matches your hair color, right?
Tasha: 你可以用染眉膏
Tasha: You can use eyebrow mascara.
Alice:因为我懒得买
Alice: I'm too lazy to buy it.
Tasha: 我用染眉膏跟你这颜色还挺近哎
Tasha: I use eyebrow mascara and the color is pretty close to yours.
Tasha: 不是新买的吗
Tasha: Isn't it new?
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This one.
Alice:是这颜色吗
Alice: Is it this color?
Alice:这颜色跟我头发不太像哎
Alice: This color doesn't really match my hair.
Alice:还可以但我已经画了就这样
Alice: It's okay, but I've already done it, so let's leave it.
Alice:你是不是一般用黑色的眉毛
Alice: Do you usually use black eyebrows?
Alice:或者棕色的
Alice: Or brown ones?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 我也
Lucia: Me too.
Alice:两个眉毛一点
Alice: Both eyebrows a bit.
Tasha: 明明是我画怎么就变成他自己画的
Tasha: Clearly, I did it, how did it become him doing it himself?
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 人还是习惯
Tasha: People still prefer doing it themselves.
Lucia: 自己动手丰衣足食
Lucia: Self-reliance is fulfilling.
Tasha: 下面进行我最擅长的涂口红环节
Tasha: Now, let's move on to the lipstick, which I'm best at.
Alice:哈哈好
Alice: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 观摩一下人类珍贵涂口红资料
Lucia: Let's observe the precious process of humans applying lipstick.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:行那今天就涂这个样子
Alice: Alright, let's go with this look today.
Alice:所以我就会
Alice: So I will...
Alice:你会化卧蚕吗会
Alice: Do you know how to draw aegyo-sal?
Tasha: 我吗嗯
Tasha: Me? Hmm.
Tasha: 我我我觉得我会
Tasha: I think I can.
Tasha: 你相信我吗
Tasha: Do you trust me?
Tasha: 我给你来一个
Tasha: Let me do it for you.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 这个口红颜色好看
Lucia: This lipstick color is pretty.
Tasha: 好哈哈
Tasha: Nice, haha.
Lucia: 真的很好看
Lucia: It really looks good.
Alice:跟我那个颜色好像
Alice: It looks similar to mine.
Lucia: 我我买我买我买
Lucia: I'll buy it, I'll buy it!
Lucia: 口红老是要么就买了颜色深了
Lucia: Lipsticks always end up being too dark...
Lucia: 要么就买颜色太淡了的感觉
Lucia: ...or too light, that's how it feels.
Alice:麻烦麻烦
Alice: Such a hassle.
Tasha: 下我来
Tasha: Let me go next.
Alice:我要我要浅一点的
Alice: I want a lighter one.
Tasha: 粉色的
Tasha: Pink?
Alice:粉色卧蚕
Alice: Pink aegyo-sal.
Alice:嗯无所谓来吧
Alice: Hmm, whatever, go ahead.
Tasha: 笑吧
Tasha: Smile.
Alice:就这样
Alice: Just like this.
Tasha: 笑笑
Tasha: 不是这个吧
Tasha: Is this it?
Alice:就行就行
Alice: It's fine, it's fine.
Tasha: 笑起来
Tasha: Smile.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 笑
Tasha: Smile.
Alice:这无产品还挺好用的
Alice: This product is quite good.
Tasha: 好你相信就好
Tasha: Good, as long as you believe it.
Tasha: 这个像
Tasha: This looks like...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:这什么
Alice: What's this?
Tasha: 那你卧蚕本身就很深呀
Tasha: Your aegyo-sal is already quite pronounced.
Alice:这好像眼袋
Alice: This looks like eye bags.
Tasha: 嗯下面就是
Tasha: Hmm, underneath, yes.
Jake: 我们顺着拿啊
Jake: Let's grab them in order.
Jake: 不要按顺
Jake: Don't go out of order.
Tasha: 啊这么深
Tasha: Oh, this deep?
Tasha: 你是不是下手太重了
Tasha: Did you go too hard?
Alice:我确实因为我没有专门的东西
Alice: I did because I don't have the proper tools.
Alice:但是我一般会把它再擦掉
Alice: But I usually wipe it off again.
Alice:我那个小头
Alice: My small brush...
Alice:那个小头在哪里
Alice: Where's that small brush?
Alice:啊我一般在用这个把它给涂掉
Alice: Ah, I usually use this to smear it off.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 修硕啊
Tasha: Shure.
Tasha: 修硕你会打麻将吗
Tasha: Shure, do you know how to play Mahjong?
Shure: 会啊
Shure: Yeah, I do.
Tasha: 我们下午要收集一些麻将素材
Tasha: We need to collect some Mahjong footage this afternoon.
Tasha: 你愿意
Tasha: Are you willing?
Shure: 太好了
Shure: Great.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 就等这个呢
Shure: I've been waiting for this.
Katrina: 饭来了二楼吃还是在这里吃
Katrina: The food is here, are we eating on the second floor or here?
Tasha: 应该是在2楼吃吧装满
Tasha: We should eat on the second floor, fill it up.
Katrina: 你们在干嘛
Katrina: What are you guys doing?
Tasha: 录化妆数据
Tasha: Recording makeup data.
Lucia: 化妆哈哈
Lucia: Makeup, haha.
Shure: 上楼
Shure: Let's go upstairs.
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure: 去哪吃二楼
Shure: Where to eat, second floor?
Lucia: 走吗宝贝们
Lucia: Shall we go, darlings?
Tasha: 可以要不要
Tasha: Sure, do you want to?
Tasha: 呃先吃饭先
Tasha: Uh, let's eat first.
Tasha: 不涂口红了吧
Tasha: No more lipstick, right?
Alice:不涂腮红结束
Alice: No more blush, it's done.
Tasha: 你这一盘化所有
Tasha: You put on all the makeup in one go.
Alice:我没有东西吗
Alice: Do I not have the stuff?
Tasha: 人果然更喜欢给自己画
Tasha: People really prefer doing their own makeup.
Lucia: 那我买一个星空灯
Lucia: Then I'll buy a starry lamp.
Lucia: 放在房间里就可以了哦
Lucia: Just put it in the room, it'll be fine.
Lucia: 我们是不是现在不讨论这个
Lucia: Aren't we not discussing this now?
Alice:你说可以吗
Alice: Do you think it's okay?
Tasha: ok夹子
Tasha: Okay, the clip.
Lucia: 哪里还有一个
Lucia: Where's another one?
Tasha: 来把这个也去了吧
Tasha: Come, let's take this off too.
Alice:也不录了
Alice: Not recording anymore.
Lucia: 我们是不是可可以把它停一下或者之类的
Lucia: Can we stop it or something like that?
Alice:嗯充电
Alice: Hmm, charging.
Lucia: 吃饭的时候不录
Lucia: Don't record while eating.
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Alice:好妆前妆后拍一下哈哈
Alice: Alright, let's take a before and after makeup shot, haha.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yeah.
Tasha: 拜拜
Tasha: Bye-bye.
Alice:拜拜吃饭
Alice: Bye-bye, let's eat.